This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之二，保证真人。百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析科学，探讨如何在神奇的现代世界中培养精神韧性、体能以及建立抗压能力。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。也就是数字 2。可以在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back At It》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着去理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员以及我们喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听 Look Back at It。嘿，你们好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间专门讨论黑人男性的经历，进行坦诚的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方说其实都不安全，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的执照专业人士进行对话。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在 AHA 广播应用、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生育了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。在 iheart radio app、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。大家好，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个探讨我们二十多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转型及其含义的播客。
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners. It is so great to have you here back for another episode, one that I am so excited to be able to do today. I have an amazing guest till I'll introduce to you in just a second. But something that's been on my mind a lot recently is the idea of adversity and how
为了我们的心理学。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客，新听友，老听友。很高兴你能来到这里，收听又一期节目，今天这一期我非常兴奋能够录制。我有一位很棒的嘉宾，我一会儿就会向你介绍。但最近有一件事经常占据我的脑海，那就是逆境的理念以及如何
we can overcome the things that are in our path, the things that fate kind of hands us and life hands us to become full, amazing, flourishing individuals in our 20s. And today I have on Bradley, the host of the show a lot to talk about. How are you Bradley? I'm so well, and I have to say, you need to get some sort of contract or deal with calm. Because your voice is like, It puts me into like a meditative state. It's great. It's a very peaceful way to spend a podcast. So I'm absolutely stoked to be here and I love your show.
我们可以战胜阻碍在我们道路上的事物，战胜命运和生活抛给我们的事物，从而在我们二十多岁时成为全面、精彩、蓬勃发展的人。今天我请到了节目主持人布拉德利来聊聊很多事情。布拉德利，你好吗？我很好，我必须说，你需要和 Calm 签某种合同或达成协议。因为你的声音就像，它让我进入了一种冥想的状态。太棒了。这是度过播客时间的一种非常平和的方式。所以我绝对非常高兴能来到这里，我也很喜欢你的节目。
Just so excited to be a part of it. Thank you. And for those of you who don't know, I was on Bradley's show this week. We talked about our 20s and all the things that come with it. It was such an amazing experience. I feel like I very rarely have other Australians on the show. So this is like super special to me. It's so exciting anytime that I think especially in this space,
非常高兴能参与其中。谢谢你。对于那些不知道的人来说，我这周上了布拉德利的节目。我们讨论了我们的二十岁以及随之而来的所有事情。这是一次非常棒的体验。我觉得我在节目中很少能邀请到其他澳大利亚人。所以这对我来说就像是超级特别。每当我想到这一点时，尤其是在这个领域，我都觉得非常兴奋，
Jim, because there are so many people doing great things in the US market, the UK market. And I think that Australia is always seen as like we're a little bit behind in this space of media, in the space of podcasting in particular. So the fact that, you know,
吉姆，因为在美国市场、英国市场有太多人在做着伟大的事情。而且我认为澳大利亚总是被视为在这个媒体领域、特别是在播客领域有点落后。所以事实上，你知道，
we've been able to meet, connect on very similar interests and goals for what we're doing in this space and then to be able to collaborate on, you know, an episode on my show, an episode on your show is it's a real joy. It really is. And I think it's one of those things, right, when you find people who share a passion. It's just so incredible and it always creates such an amazing friendship.
我们能够相遇，就我们在该领域的兴趣和目标达成共识并建立联系，然后能够合作，你知道的，在我的一期节目上，在你的节目上，真是一件乐事。确实如此。我认为这就是其中之一，对吧，当你找到志同道合的人时。这真是太不可思议了，它总是能建立起如此美妙的友谊。
And I think the thing that really, really brought me towards your energy and really attracted me to your energy was you have such a unique and incredible story that I think is so inspiring and worth sharing. You know, we talk a lot about the somewhat universally. experiences of our 20s on the show. We talk about personal growth. But something I think that we need to discuss more is things that are kind of put in our path, things that we have to overcome for you as a chronic illness and the best way that we can kind of handle and deal with the cards that we've been dealt. You know, I think your journey and experience with cystic fibrosis is an incredible example
我想真正吸引我走向你的能量并真正吸引我关注你的能量的原因是，你有着如此独特而不可思议的故事，我认为它非常鼓舞人心，值得分享。你知道，我们在节目中经常讨论我们二十多岁时某种程度上具有普遍性的经历。我们谈论个人成长。但我认为我们需要讨论更多的是那些摆在我们面前的事情，那些我们必须克服的事情，对于你来说是慢性病，以及我们如何能够最好地处理和应对我们所拿到的一手牌。你知道，我认为你患有囊性纤维化的旅程和经历是一个不可思议的例子
of that. I know you were at Parliament House last week discussing the need for greater cover of medications used to treat this illness and you do some incredible advocacy. I might just ask, for those of us who don't know what cystic fibrosis is, can you maybe provide a bit of an overview? Yeah, I'll try to do this in the simplest, least scientific way possible because it is such a complex condition. So essentially cystic fibrosis is a genetic illness. So everyone, which is about 3,600 Australians who have CF and live with it every day, were all born with it. It's not something you can develop later in life it's not something you can catch you were born with it it's two parents having the cystic fibrosis gene which causes um a chance not a super likely chance but a
我知道你上周在议会大厦讨论了加强对治疗这种疾病的药物的覆盖范围的必要性，而且你做了一些令人难以置信的倡导工作。我可能想问一下，对于那些不知道什么是囊性纤维化的人，你能简单介绍一下吗？好的，我会尽量用最简单、最不科学的方式来解释，因为这是一种非常复杂的疾病。从本质上讲，囊性纤维化是一种遗传性疾病。所以每个人，大约有 3,600 名患有囊性纤维化并在日常生活中与之共存的澳大利亚人，都是天生就患有这种疾病的。这不是你以后生活中会得的病，也不是你能传染上的，你是生来就有的，它是两个父母携带了囊性纤维化基因，这会导致一种几率，不是超级高的几率，但
enough of a chance i believe it's about four percent chance where two people carry the cf gene that their child is born with cf now essentially cf has what we call different mutations of the illness but there's particularly one that is the most common and also the most severe it's called delta f5 o i weight. So that's as scientific as I'm going to get. But essentially what that means is it means that anyone who has that genetic mutation of CF often has issues with their lungs. So because essentially CF is a defective gene that's supposed to transport salt and water to the cells in the body. And where those cells don't get the appropriate salt and water through that gene, essentially the mucus that moves around the body, it gets thicker and stickier and it sits on and impairs the functions of
足够的几率，我相信大约有百分之四的几率，两个携带CF基因的人会生出一个患有CF的孩子。现在，本质上CF有我们称之为不同的疾病突变，但特别有一种是最常见的，也是最严重的，它被称为 delta f5 o i weight。这就是我能做到的最科学的解释了。但从本质上讲，这意味着任何拥有这种 CF 基因突变的人通常都会有肺部问题。因为本质上CF是一个有缺陷的基因，它应该将盐和水输送到身体的细胞中。如果这些细胞没有通过该基因获得适当的盐和水，那么本质上在体内移动的粘液就会变得更厚、更黏，它会附着并损害
organs and also scars them. So in the lungs, it means that, you know, we all associate sort of mucus or phlegm with the lungs and the respiratory system. Essentially, that mucus sits there and creates a breeding ground for infection. And that's how a lot of people with CF have a lot of their struggles, you know, lung infection after lung infection. That means the depreciating health of their lungs become quite scarred and they can't breathe properly and they struggle to get air in and out. And for a lot of people with CF, it means that. that the capacity of air they can get into their lungs is quite heavily reduced, but also it feels like, you know, every time you take a breath,
器官并使它们留下疤痕。所以在肺部，这意味着，你知道，我们都把某种粘液或痰与肺部和呼吸系统联系起来。本质上，这种粘液滞留在那儿，为感染创造了滋生地。这就是许多 CF 患者经历很多痛苦的原因，你知道，肺部感染接连不断。这意味着他们肺部的健康状况不断恶化，留下了很多疤痕，他们无法正常呼吸，难以将空气吸入和呼出。对于许多 CF 患者来说，这意味着他们吸入肺部的空气容量大大减少了，而且感觉就像，你知道，每次你呼吸时，
you're sort of breathing through a straw. So it can be quite challenging just in the everyday and almost every breath for people with CF. It's also quite common that people with CF suffer from pancreatic insufficiency. And essentially what that means is anytime I eat food with protein or fat in it, my body doesn't produce the appropriate digestive enzymes to absorb that nutrition. and taking what the body needs to, you know, grow, thrive and recover. And so I have to take digestive enzymes in capsule form every time I eat any food with protein or fat in it.
你有点像在通过一根吸管呼吸。所以对于 CF 患者来说，在日常生活中甚至是每一次呼吸都可能是相当具有挑战性的。CF 患者还经常患有胰腺功能不全。本质上这意味着，每当我吃含有蛋白质或脂肪的食物时，我的身体都不会产生适当的消化酶来吸收这些营养。并吸收身体成长、茁壮成长和恢复所需的营养。因此，每次我吃任何含有蛋白质或脂肪的食物时，我都必须以胶囊形式服用消化酶。
Now, for me, it also meant that at the age of nine, I was diagnosed with liver disease. I actually have cirrhosis of the liver, which is what sort of an alcoholic would get after 20 years of abusing their liver with alcohol. And I've also got diabetes because of that pancreatic insufficiency. So there's a lot of things that come with cystic fibrosis, and it's quite often thought of as a lung disease, but it's so much more than that. And it's why it's such a complex disease to understand for so many Aussies.
现在，对我来说，这也意味着在我九岁时，我被诊断出患有肝病。我实际上患有肝硬化，这有点像一个酗酒者虐待肝脏 20 年后会得的病。而且因为胰腺功能不全，我还患了糖尿病。所以囊性纤维化伴随着很多问题，它通常被认为是一种肺部疾病，但它远不止于此。这也是为什么对于许多澳大利亚人来说，它是一种如此难以理解的复杂疾病。
It's also why so many people with CF live really hard lives because there are so many things in the body that can go wrong and often do go wrong with CF. That is such an eloquent way of putting it and so understandable, I think. it's really interesting these kind of illnesses and these kinds of, I don't know if I would classify it as a disease, it's an illness, it's a chronic illness, right? And we were talking about this the other day where you just gave me this incredible list of all these things that your body is going through and these almost, this like very intense physical experiences, but it's really
这也是为什么许多 CF 患者过着非常艰难的生活，因为身体里有太多事情可能会出错，而且在 CF 中经常出错。这真是一种绝妙的表达方式，而且我认为非常容易理解。这些类型的疾病真的很有趣，这些类型的，我不知道我是否会把它归类为疾病，它是一种疾病，一种慢性病，对吧？我们前几天在讨论这件事，当时你只是向我列出了一个令人难以置信的清单，列出了你的身体正在经历的所有这些事情，以及几乎这些非常激烈的身体体验，但它真的
interesting, I think, that we were talking about how you don't always look sick and you don't look like someone who has, you know, dysfunction in your liver. You don't look like someone who has diabetes. But I'm sure as a child that was really different and you probably had a lot of really hard days. Do you think your experiences in childhood really have impacted you today? Like when did you realize that you weren't like other people that you had these complications or these elements of this illness? that's such a great question because there are a few answers to that i guess for me i was born into
有趣，我认为，我们讨论了你如何并不总是看起来生病，你看起来不像一个肝功能有问题的人。你看起来不像一个有糖尿病的人。但我确信在童年时期情况大不相同，你可能经历了很多艰难的日子。你认为你童年时期的经历真的对你今天的产生了影响吗？就像你什么时候意识到自己和别人不一样，自己有这些并发症或这种疾病的元素？这是一个非常棒的问题，因为对此有几个答案，我想对我来说，我出生在
this incredible family so i say that literally the greatest gift and blessing i ever received was two incredible parents when i was diagnosed with cystic fibrosis it was just a couple months later my parents were sitting in front of a cystic fibrosis specialist essentially the man who is going to provide the information provide the understanding and set them up for what to expect as parents of a child with CF and he sat them down and within a matter of minutes said your son would be better off with a terminal illness that would kill him or he'd get over because cystic fibrosis will ruin his life like he said it with such certainty that they sat there and were sort of taken aback by it they've gone far out like that's so negative but what my parents
这个不可思议的家庭所以我字面意思是，我收到的最好的礼物和祝福是两个不可思议的父母。当我被诊断出患有囊性纤维化时，仅仅几个月后，我的父母坐在一个囊性纤维化专家的面前，本质上这个人将提供信息，提供理解，并为他们作为患有CF的孩子的父母做好心理准备，他让他们坐下来，在几分钟内说，你的儿子最好得一个能致命的绝症，或者他能挺过去，因为囊性纤维化会毁了他的生活。他说的太肯定了，以至于他们坐在那里，有点被吓到了，他们想，天哪，这也太消极了吧，但是我的父母
done was they stood up looked him in the face and said you'll never see us again and walked out of that room and they decided to go and see a doctor who had a more positive view, the same positive view that they shared for my life and they taught me this incredible lesson before I even knew it that what you believe is what you become. And so throughout the course of my early childhood years, we had this extremely positive perspective for what my life could and should look like regardless of my cystic fibrosis. And in my early years, that was reinforced, that belief was reinforced through my ability to compete in athletic endeavors. I was a really fit, healthy, able young kid. And I was a state champion sprinter. And I had a younger sister. She's two and a half
做的是他们站起来，直视他的眼睛，说你再也见不到我们了，然后走出了那个房间。他们决定去看另一位医生，这位医生对我的生活有着更积极的看法，和他们持有相同的积极看法。在我甚至还不知道的时候，他们就教给我这不可思议的一课：你相信什么，你就会成为什么。因此，在我的幼儿时期，对于我的生活不论囊性纤维化如何可以而且应该是什么样，我们都有着极其积极的视角。在我的早年，这种信念通过我参加竞技体育的能力得到了强化。我是一个非常健康、充满活力、有能力的年轻孩子。我是一名州冠军短跑运动员。我还有一个妹妹。她比我小两岁半
years younger than me. She doesn't have CF. But as an older brother, you know, I would sit up at the dinner table every night and take six to ten digestive enzymes with my dinner. It's just, you know, some of the 50 tablets a day I took as a child. And my sister loved, adored me. And my sister loved, adored and admired me so much that she would have to have strawberry or orange vitamins so that she could be like her older brother. Oh my gosh. And so I credit my sister with building this amazing self-esteem in me as a young man that regardless of everything that was different with me, I never felt ashamed of it because for me, my SIF
比我小。她没有CF。但作为一个哥哥，你知道的，我每天晚上都会坐在餐桌旁，在吃晚饭时服用6到10种消化酶。这只是，你知道，我小时候每天吃的50片药片中的一部分。我的妹妹非常爱我、崇拜我。我的妹妹非常爱我、崇拜我、钦佩我，以至于她不得不吃草莓或橙子维生素，这样她才能像她的哥哥一样。哦，天哪。因此，我将我的妹妹视为在我年轻时建立这种惊人的自尊心的功臣，无论我有何不同，我从未为此感到羞耻，因为对我来说，我的 SIF
was a badge of honor. My sister looked at me because when you're young, your siblings and your family are the people you spend your time with before you enter your schooling life. And in the very early years, my CF was not something that held me back. In fact, it's something my sister admired about me. So for me, this self-esteem was built that I don't have to look at this any differently. And in fact, I've been told there's all these things I shouldn't be able to do, but I'm able to do them.
是一个荣誉勋章。我妹妹看着我，因为当你年轻时，在你进入学校生活之前，你的兄弟姐妹和家人是你花时间相处的人。在最初的几年里，我的CF并没有阻碍我。事实上，这是我妹妹钦佩我的地方。所以对我来说，这种自尊心的建立是，我不需要以任何不同的方式看待这件事。事实上，有人告诉我所有这些我不应该做的事情，但我能够做到。
So that makes me more resilient. It makes me stronger. And I should actually be proud of this. And I think it speaks to the importance. You know, we talk about childhood trauma a lot and how that shapes us as human, beings as we enter adulthood, well, in the very early foundational years of my life, my family gave me every reason to believe that cystic fibrosis wouldn't limit or defy my life. And so those early years, I was so healthy. It was more for me that when I entered adulthood, a little bit of
所以这让我更有韧性。这让我更坚强。我其实应该为此感到自豪。我认为这说明了它的重要性。你知道，我们经常讨论童年创伤以及它如何在我们进入成年期时塑造我们作为人类，好吧，在我生命中非常早期的基础时期，我的家人给了我充分的理由相信囊性纤维化不会限制或定义我的生活。所以在那些早期的岁月里，我是如此健康。对我来说，更多的是当我进入成年期时，一点点
complacency allowed some of those challenges to creep in. And I guess to answer your question and to sort of, I guess, lean on and touch on what you were saying before. It wasn't really until I was 18 years of age that CF really started to challenge me. And the first challenge was a really severe case of bleeding lungs. And it was the first time I ever remember thinking, far out, I'm mortal. I actually, I'm not just beating CF. I'm not miles ahead of it. It's caught up to me and it's something I now have to learn to live with.
自满让其中一些挑战潜入进来。我想为了回答你的问题，并且顺着并提及你之前所说的话。直到我18岁时，CF才真正开始挑战我。第一个挑战是一个非常严重的肺出血病例。这是我第一次记得自己想，天哪，我是会死的。我实际上，我不仅仅是在战胜 CF。我并没有把数英里甩在身后。它已经追上了我，这是我现在必须学会与之共存的事情。
and that was for me a little bit of a shock. But I think because my foundational beliefs were so strong and positive and I'd built so much resilience through just providing myself with this undeniable proof that I can achieve in spite of CF, that I was able to tackle that with a really level head. I genuinely got chills when you were talking about your parents' reaction to that doctor and your sister as well. That is such a remarkable response.
对我和我来说，这有点震惊。但我认为，因为我的基础信念如此坚定和积极，而且我通过为自己提供不可否认的证明（即我可以在尽管有CF的情况下取得成就）建立了很多韧性，所以我能够以非常平和的心态应对这一切。当你谈到你的父母对那个医生的反应以及你妹妹的反应时，我真的起鸡皮疙瘩了。这真是一个非凡的反应。
And honestly, like, breathtaking that they just sound like such incredible role models. I'm so happy for you that you had that kind of support structure and such kick-ass parents. Like, they genuinely sound incredible. And I think that it was a really good point you said in the sense that the environment that your family creates for you as a child really shapes your mindset towards adversity. really shapes your mindset towards the things that everyone is going to have to encounter and overcome. I just think that is such a profound and compelling example of how that works. The fact that you're still able to excel, the fact that you were able to perhaps not even recognize that you were sick or ill until you were an adult because your parents almost
说实话，他们听起来简直就像不可思议的榜样，这太令人惊叹了。我真为你高兴，你能拥有那种支持系统以及如此了不起的父母。他们的确听起来太棒了。我觉得你刚才说得特别好，那就是你的家庭在孩童时期为你创造的环境，真的塑造了你面对逆境的心态。真的塑造了你对待每个人都必须遭遇和克服的事情的心态。我只是觉得这是一个无比深刻且引人注目的例子，说明了这一切是如何运作的。你依然能够出类拔萃，甚至直到成年你可能都完全没意识到自己生病了或身体不适，因为你的父母几乎
created this protective spear around you of, of, not so much like of just normalcy, of normalcy and also of, of capability and of inspiration. 100%. And I think as a child, you kind of process the world through feeling and emotion as opposed to, you know, like I think that belief system that I strongly identify with now of being quite positive and feeling quite capable in spite of my challenges. as a kid you don't see it that way you just think this is how I am and this is how we are as a family and that's just something you can feel and something you you know as a as a sense of the way that you live your life it's very subconscious where I think now you know I have the beauty of hindsight understanding being a 26 year old man who you know is able to look back on all of those moments and draw the lessons from them and better understand them and now I can fully process not
为你创造了一根保护长矛，里面充满了……与其说是充满……不如说全是正常，充满正常，同时也充满能力和启发。百分之百。而且我认为，作为一个孩子，你对世界的处理是通过感觉和情绪，而不是像我现在这样强烈认同的信念系统——即尽管面临挑战，依然非常积极且觉得自己很有能力。作为一个孩子，你不会那样看待它，你只会觉得这就是我本来的样子，这就是我们作为家庭的样子，这只是一种你能感受到的东西，一种你生活方式的感觉，它是非常潜意识的。而我觉得现在，我拥有后见之明的优势，作为一个26岁的年轻人，我能够回顾所有这些时刻并从中汲取教训，更好地理解它们，现在我可以完全地处理，不是
subconsciously but consciously that they are the lessons that my parents were teaching me and they led through action which was just such a blessing to have that I guess that support system around me from you know my first days yeah absolutely and it's such a credit to them but I think I also a credit to you that you were able to adapt and be such a flexible child and really persevere this is kind of leading on to this other question and I think it's one that I'm sure other people have asked you, but I just, I just think it's so valuable to understand how CF, how this illness has really impacted you mentally. I think from my perspective of you, it's in some ways actually empowered you because you've, this obstacle has been put in your way and you've kind of been like,
凭潜意识，而是凭有意识地去理解，这些就是父母一直在教给我的教训，他们通过实际行动来引领，能在我生命的最初日子里拥有那样的支持系统、那种周围的支持，真是一大幸事。是的，绝对如此，这不仅归功于他们，但我也认为这归功于你，因为你能够适应并成为一个如此灵活的孩子，真正地坚持不懈。这就引出了另一个问题，我觉得这个问题肯定别人也问过你，但我只是……我只是觉得理解囊性纤维化（CF），这个疾病如何在精神上真正影响了你，是如此宝贵。从我对你的看法来看，它在某种程度上实际上赋予了你力量，因为你……这个障碍挡在了你的路上，而你有点像是，
no, I'm not going to, I'm not going to take this. This isn't how my life is going to be. but I'm sure there's a lot of nuance behind that. So how has it impacted you psychologically and mentally? There's definitely positives. Well, there are so many positives. I'll say that. There are so many positives that, like you said, I recognize this incredible purpose in my life
不，我不会……我不会接受这个。我的生活不该是这样的。但我确信这背后有很多细微差别。那么它在心理和精神上是如何影响你的呢？肯定有积极的一面。嗯，有非常多的积极面。我会这么说。有如此多的积极面，就像你说的，我认识到我生命中有一个不可思议的目标，
that is because of the challenges I've faced. I recognize this resilience that is a huge part of who I am as a human being and allows me to continue to do what I do. I recognize incredible perspective. because for all the challenges I've faced, I appreciate the gift of every day having air in my lungs and a heartbeat. I also appreciate the people in my life because they've been a huge part of allowing me to be where I am as healthy as I am today. However, I'll touch on because I think it would be handy for people listening and there's been such a lesson in this over the course of the last few years for me. I think the challenges I had that I didn't really understand until I was in my early 20s
这正是因为我所面对的挑战。我认识到了韧性，它构成了我作为人类核心的一部分，并让我能够继续做我所做的事。我认识到了不可思议的人生视角。因为经历了所有的挑战，我感激肺里有空气、心脏在跳动的每一天的恩赐。我也感激我生命中的人，因为他们让我能够走到今天，保持如今这样健康的体魄，这其中他们扮演了极其重要的角色。不过，我要谈谈这一点，因为我觉得这对听众会很有帮助，在过去几年的时间里，对我来说这其中有着深刻的教训。我认为我曾有过的一些挑战，直到我二十岁出头才真正理解，
that were a negative, I guess a negative view on my CF was I had this insecurity that as I entered adulthood and started to face some of these challenges, you know, bleeding lungs and a little bit of uncertainty surrounding my CF and my health long term. I had a worry and a fear that as a man who wanted to be a father, as a man who wanted to be a father, as a man who wanted to have, you know, a woman in his life that he loved, adored and was able to create a relationship with and a life with. I had this fear and insecurity that because of the uncertainty of my CF, why would someone bet their chips on me?
那是一种负面的看法，我想是对我CF的一种负面看法：当我步入成年并开始面对其中一些挑战时，我有一种不安全感，你知道的，肺部出血以及围绕我的CF和长期健康的一些不确定性。我有一种担忧和恐惧：作为一个想成为父亲的男人，作为一个想成为父亲的男人，作为一个想拥有一个他所爱、崇拜并且能够与之建立关系和生活的女人的男人，我有这样一种恐惧和不安全感：由于我的CF的不确定性，为什么会有人把筹码押在我身上？
Why would someone choose to enter a relationship with someone they didn't fully have the certainty that they'd have a future with? And it was this insecurity that for a long time stopped me from. really stepping into any sort of potential long-term relationships and, you know, all the self-sabotage in the world and all the excuses as to why, you know, this isn't right and that isn't right. And ultimately, a lot of the potential relationships I had in my early 20s weren't the right people for me anyways. But I had this fear that I just never find the right person. And it definitely troubled me at times because I've never felt alone. I've got incredible
为什么会有人选择和一个无法完全确定是否有未来的人建立恋爱关系？正是这种不安全感，在很长一段时间里阻止了我真正去涉足任何潜在的长期恋爱关系，你知道的，世界上所有的自我怀疑，以及关于为什么“这个不对”或“那个不对”的种种借口。归根结底，我二十岁出头时经历的许多潜在恋爱对象反正也不是最适合我的人。但我有一种恐惧，那就是我永远找不到对的人。它有时确实让我感到困扰，因为我从未感到孤独。我有不可思议的
friends and once again incredible family but i did feel a sense of loneliness and loneliness was something that i definitely struggled with at times throughout the early 20s of my life you know and i remember moving to i moved to melbourne in 2018 for work and so out of my comfort zone because i was so far from my family you know as a flight or an eight hour drive from my family i was away from all of my friends and i had quite a hectic job where I worked seven days a week, 12 hours a day. And it didn't leave much time for anything else in my life. But I was staying and living in a two-bedroom apartment by myself. And I remember sitting in front of the TV, getting home from work at like 9, 30, 10 o'clock every night and just thinking, far out, it would be nice to have someone that I could at least know
朋友，还有同样不可思议的家人，但我确实有一种孤独感，孤独确实是我在我生命中二十岁出头时有时与之抗争的东西，你知道的。我记得我搬到了……我于2018年为了工作搬到了墨尔本，这完全超出了我的舒适区，因为我离家人太远了，你知道的，坐飞机或开车八小时才能到家，我远离了我所有的朋友，而且我有一份相当忙碌的工作，一周工作七天，一天工作十二小时。这没有给我生活中的其他事情留下太多时间。但我独自一人住在一套两居室的公寓里。我记得自己坐在电视机前，每天晚上九点半、十点左右下班回家，然后就在想，天哪，要是能有个人，哪怕能让我知道
I was sacrificing to build a life with. And there was so much that was flawed in my own relationship with myself at the time but I I just always seen cystic fibrosis is almost a roadblock to ever having that and it wasn't until I started to and I don't want to skip too far ahead in the story because I'm sure we'll get there but it wasn't really until I started to take control of my health again until I started to really you know willingly choose to suffer and do hard things and be disciplined and create purpose, challenge, goals in my life, that I found this new sense of confidence that, well, actually, there is so much I can control. And through podcasting, podcasting has made a man out of me, and I don't say that lightly,
我所做出的牺牲是为了共同建立生活，那该有多好。当时我对自己的关系的认知存在着太多的缺陷，但我……我总是把囊性纤维化视为拥有那种生活的绊脚石。直到我开始——我不想在故事里跳得太快，因为我相信我们总会讲到那里的——直到我真正开始重新掌控自己的健康，直到我真正开始……你知道的，甘愿承受痛苦、去做困难的事情、保持自律、为生活创造目标和挑战，我才找到了这种全新的自信：其实，有太多事情是我可以掌控的。而通过做播客，播客造就了我这个男子汉，我这话可不是轻描淡写说出来的，
hearing other people's stories, developing my own understanding of, you know, the human being that I am, the way that the world works, the way that we work as human beings, allowed me to realize this incredible lesson that in fact none of us are guaranteed any time here on earth that literally if you wake up tomorrow with air in your lungs and a heartbeat you've been given an incredible gift and so to think that you are and i say this to people with cf all the time or with chronic illness there is no such thing as life expectancy because no one's promised any day on this earth and so every day if you get up and control what you can control and do what you can do to be at your best,
倾听别人的故事，培养自己对以下事物的理解：我是什么样的人，世界是如何运转的，我们作为人类是如何运转的，这让我意识到一个不可信的教训：事实上，我们没有人在地球上能获得时间的担保，如果你明天醒来时肺里有空气、心脏在跳动， literalmente（字面意义上）你已经得到了不可思议的恩赐。因此，如果你认为你是……我对患有CF或慢性病的人经常这么说，根本没有什么所谓的“预期寿命”，因为没有人被承诺能在地球上多活一天。所以每一天，如果你起床并掌控你能掌控的事，做好你能做的事来达到最佳状态，
well then you're in the same boat as everyone else. So I just decided to stop looking at it as a limiting factor. And with that, funnily enough, I've found someone that I love dearly, that I am creating a life with, that I now do not feel like cystic fibrosis is holding me back or limiting any area of my life. And so that has probably been to answer your question
那么你就和所有人站在同一起跑线上。所以我只是决定不再把它看作是一个限制因素。说来也巧，随着这一点，我找到了一个我深爱的人，我们正在共同创造生活，现在我觉得囊性纤维化再也没有阻碍我或限制我生活的任何领域。所以，要回答你这个问题，
in the longest way possible. The only rule negative that I've felt, living a life with cystic fibrosis. But I feel like now, as I look in the rearview mirror at what once was a limiting belief, I feel very liberated to know that today there's not a single thing within my world, within my life that I see as an issue
用最长的方式来回答，这就是我带着囊性纤维化生活所感受到的唯一的真正负面影响。但我觉得现在，当我回视曾经的那个限制性信念时，我感到非常解放，因为我知道今天在我的世界里、在我的生活中，没有哪怕一件事被我视为是
to moving forward with cystic fibrosis. I'm so happy for you. I love that response. I think that's just such a testament to your character that you're at this place. There's this saying that I love, love that it's like every every, every bad thing, every twist of fate is meant to bring you to the place that you are. And I do genuinely believe it. I don't know if you think this as well, but
带着囊性纤维化继续前行的障碍。我太为你高兴了。我很喜欢这个回答。我觉得这绝对证明了你的品格，证明了你如今所处的境界。我有一句很喜欢的话，非常喜欢，大意是：每一次不顺、每一次命运的转折，都是为了把你带到你现在所处的地方。我确实深信这一点。我不知道你是否也这么认为，但
looking at my own life and something that I was reflecting on when you were talking about that is there have been so many times in my life where I've been in that state of loneliness or where things have gone wrong, where I haven't gotten what I've wanted, where something has come up that has really distorted my vision of the future. And I've been like, that's the end. Like, I didn't get what I wanted. I deserve to be miserable now. I'm going to kind of sit in myself pity.
审视我自己的生活，当我听到你谈论这些时，我所反思的一点是：在我的人生中，有无数次我曾陷入那种孤独的状态，或者事情出错的时候，当我没有得到我想要的东西时，当某些事情真正扭曲了我对未来的愿景时。我曾觉得，那就是终点。就像，我没有得到我想要的。我现在就活该痛苦。我要陷在自怜自艾里。
But all of those things, all of those instances, like when you were in Melbourne, where you were sitting in this state of almost like despair and really questioning things, they're all meant to bring you to this point. They're meant to teach you an important lesson. about where you should take your life. And for you, that is to become an amazing advocate, an amazing podcaster, an amazing partner as well. But what do you think was that turning point in your mindset?
但所有这些事情，所有这些时刻，就像你在墨尔本时，坐在那种近乎绝望的状态中并真正质疑一切的时候，它们其实都是为了把你带到这个点。它们是为了教给你一个重要的课程，关于你应该把生活带向何方。对你而言，那就是成为一个出色的倡导者、出色的播客主持人，同时也是一个出色的伴侣。但你认为你心态的转折点是什么？
What do you think was that moment where the flip kind of switched for you? It's such a great question, Jen, because there are so many things that have played equal part in building the new mentality that I have, in developing my mindset to be where it is to move forward in life right now. And I'll go through a few of them. So when I do a keynote, I center my keynote around four life-changing moments
你认为那个让你的思维方式发生转变的时刻是什么？这真是个好问题，詹（Jen），因为有太多事情在构建我新的心态方面发挥了同等重要的作用，在培养我的心智、让我能够朝着目前的生活大步迈进方面也是如此。我会列举其中几个。当我做主题演讲时，我把主题演讲围绕着四个改变人生的时刻展开，
that have led to four life-changing lessons. Now, the first moment is the moment I spoke about when I was diagnosed. I always draw back on that. Even today, I think about that moment every day. The second is the first time that I thought I was dying. So I spoke about being 18 and having bleeding lungs for the first time. I remember, you know, being quite ill over the course of a week and knowing that I had to go into hospital.
这四个时刻带来了四个人生改变的教训。现在，第一个时刻就是我被诊断出病情的那个时刻。我总是回想起那个时刻。即使在今天，我每天都会想起那个时刻。第二个时刻是我第一次觉得自己快要死了。所以我刚才提到过18岁时第一次肺部出血。我记得，你知道的，在一周的时间里病得很重，并且知道我必须住院。
And we're waiting for a hospital bed to pop up and be free at RPA Hospital in Sydney. And so they sent me home to my place at Wollongong with my old man at the time. And we were just sitting on the lounge, relaxing. I was quite sick, coughing quite a bit, a lot of mucus in my lungs. And as I was waiting for this call, I had this particularly sharp cough that was different to any time I've ever coughed in my life before that, because I could taste that metallic taste of blood in my mouth after I coughed. And I remember as soon as I tasted it, thinking about what I'd heard so many doctors say
我们在等悉尼阿尔弗雷德王子医院（RPA Hospital）腾出一张空闲的病床。于是他们让我和老爸当时一起回了卧龙岗（Wollongong）的住处。我们当时正坐在沙发上放松。我病得挺重，咳嗽得很厉害，肺里有很多黏液。就在我等电话的时候，我咳嗽了一下，这一下异常剧烈，和我以前任何一次咳嗽都不同，因为我咳完后能在嘴里尝到那种金属般的血腥味。我记得一尝到这个味道，就立刻想起了我过去几年里
to me over the course of the years prior, that if you ever cough up fresh blood, you need to race to emergency because it's a matter of life or death. And so I remember racing to the laundry, gripping the laundry sink and coughing up a load of fresh blood into the sink, looking down at the bottom of the sink and just seeing that fresh blood and experiencing the fear and anxiety just wash over your body as you just think and can't help but think the worst. I remember calling out to my old man at the top of my lungs and we raced to the car and started racing towards the emergency room at Wollongong Hospital. and I remember sitting in the car with an ice cream bucket, ice cream container in my lap to cough up the blood into and just looking at my dad and thinking, is my old man going to see me die in the car? Is he going to get to hospital in time? Is he going to have to carry me in? Is he going to be too late? Is he going to have to live with that guilt?
听过无数医生对我说过的话：如果你咳出鲜血，你必须立刻冲向急诊室，因为这是生死攸关的大事。所以我记得自己冲向洗衣房，双手死死抓着洗衣池，把一大口鲜血咳进池子里，看着水池底部，看到那些鲜血，恐惧和焦虑瞬间涌遍全身，你忍不住往最坏处想。我记得我声嘶力竭地喊着我老爸，我们冲向汽车，直奔卧龙岗医院的急诊室。我记得坐在车里，膝盖上放着一个冰淇淋桶、一个冰淇淋容器，用来吐血，我看着我爸爸心想：我老爸会眼睁睁看着我在车里死去吗？他能及时赶到医院吗？他得把我背进去吗？会不会太迟了？他以后得带着那种负罪感活下去吗？
I remember realizing that my mum and my sister weren't in the car with me and they were and still are so important to me. They're two of my closest people, and they thankfully worked at the same place of employment at the time, and I called their office, and my sister answered. And I remember having the conversation with my sister saying that we're racing to emergency. I'm coughing up a lot of blood, and I don't know what's wrong. Can your mum please meet us at emergency? I love you and tell mum I love her too. And just wondering after I hung up the phone whether I'd ever see them again.
我记得当时意识到我妈妈和妹妹并不在车上，她们对我而言过去是、现在也依然是如此重要。她们是我最亲近的两个人，当时谢天谢地她们在同一个地方上班，我给她们办公室打了电话，我妹妹接了电话。我记得和妹妹通电话时说，我们正赶往急诊室。我咳了很多血，我不知道怎么了。请妈妈能在急诊室跟我们会合好吗？我爱你，也告诉妈妈我爱她。挂断电话后，我一直在想我是否还能再见到她们。
And thankfully, my lungs stabilized and, you're going to. it was a serious case of pneumonia that took a couple weeks in hospital to recover from. But when you're 18 years of age and you literally stare what you think to be your potential death in the eyes, I had this life realisation, but I was 18. I had not lived the life I wanted to live yet. I was devastated by the idea that I was potentially leaving my family behind. And I remember thinking, I don't have. ever want to feel like that again. I don't ever want to feel like in my final moment I had so much
谢天谢地，我的肺部稳定了下来，而且，你会……那是一次严重的肺炎，在医院花了好几周才康复。但当你18岁，字面意义上直视你认为可能是死亡的东西时，我有了这样的人生感悟，但我才18岁啊。我还没有过上我想过的生活。一想到自己可能把家人抛在身后，我就心碎不已。我记得当时想，我再也不想
left to give. And, you know, I talk about this incredible Confucius quote that every man lives the second begins when he realizes he has just one. It was that moment at 18 that I realized this is my one and only life. Don't waste it. I remember a couple years later being back in hospital with a serious infection that I was told could be fatal if they didn't get a grip of it early enough and meeting an older gentleman who had terminal cancer. His name was Ernie. And I invited Ernie around to my room one afternoon just to have a conversation over a cup of tea. He was staying in the room next door in a room full of older gentlemen who were quite sick.
有这种感觉了。我再也不想在生命的最后一刻觉得，自己还有那么多
And I could tell he just needed a mate. So I invited him over. And over the course of two weeks, we spent every afternoon enjoying a cup of tea and some bickies together and just talking about life. and I remember Ernie, I vividly remember him talking about how important his people were, how much he loved. He'd actually been married three times, divorced three times, but were still mates with all his wives.
没能奉献。你知道的，我经常提到孔子的一句名言：每个人都有两次生命，但第二生命从你意识到自己其实只有一次时开始。就是18岁的那次经历让我意识到，这是我仅此一次的人生。不要浪费它。我记得几年后，我又回到了医院，感染了一种严重的疾病，医生说如果不能及早控制住，可能会致命。在那里，我遇到了一位患有晚期癌症的老绅士。他叫埃尔尼（Ernie）。有一天下午，我邀请埃尔尼来我的房间，喝杯茶聊聊天。他就住在隔壁房间，那间房里住满了病情很重的老年绅士。
I kind of love that. Yeah, he's great. He's a great man, just such an easygoing fella. Yeah. He had children, grandchildren that he loved and just cared for dearly. And not once in that whole hospital trip, you know, and at the time, I should preface that, I was so focused on making money at the time I was in real estate
我看得出来他只是需要一个朋友。所以我邀请了他。在两周的时间里，我们每天下午都一起喝茶、吃饼干，聊聊生活。我记得埃尔尼，我清晰地记得他谈到他的亲人对他有多重要，他有多爱……他其实结过三次婚，离过三次婚，但和所有前妻依然是朋友。
and my sole focus in life was to make money so that I could buy things to make me feel happy and when you're sitting in a hospital bed and you don't have the thing that should be your number one priority, your health and you're speaking to a man who is literally contemplating
我有点喜欢这个。是的，他很棒。他是个很好的人，性格非常随和。是的。他有孩子、孙子，他深爱并悉心照顾他们。在那整段住院期间，一次也没有，（当时我应该先说明一下，我当时满脑子只想赚钱，我在房地产行业工作，）
his imminent mortality and he's not once spoken about the car he drove, the house he lived in, how much money he made, he's just spoken about the people he loved. I thought, can I swear on this podcast? You sure can. I thought, well, fuck, haven't I got something wrong?
我生活中的唯一目标就是赚钱，好买能让我感到快乐的东西。而当你坐在病床上一无所有——本该成为你第一优先事项的健康却不在了——你正在和一个字面意义上在思考自己迫在眉睫的死亡的男人交谈时，他却连一次都没有谈到他开的豪车、住的豪宅、赚了多少钱，他谈论的只有他爱的人。我想——我能在播客里说脏话吗？当然可以。我想，去他妈的，我难道不是把什么搞错了吗？
And I remember leaving that hospital and not long after I quit my job and started to do what I do now. And the fourth moment I'll talk about to get back full circle to your question. I love it, please. It is July 2020, a couple months out of my job, starting to do things that I'm really passionate about and I love and starting to feel this deep sense. of what we would call purpose to uplift and inspire hope in others through story, having quite a serious three days of lung bleeds and being in an emergency room in Wollongong Hospital.
我记得离开那家医院没多久后，我就辞了职，开始做现在做的事。我要谈的第四个瞬间，好让话题绕回你的问题。太棒了，请讲。那是2020年7月，我离职几个月后，开始做那些我真正充满激情、热爱的事，并开始感受到一种深刻的感觉——也就是我们所说的使命感，通过故事去提升他人并激发希望，当时我经历了相当严重的三天肺出血，住进了卧龙岗医院的急诊室。
And sitting there with my old man at 2 a.m. whilst we waited for some test results to come back to see if, you know, I'd lost too much blood and needed a transfusion or whether they needed to do a surgery on my lungs. And I remember looking at my dad and saying, mate I feel this deep sense of clarity that not only will I recover and come back stronger than ever from this but this is my time to do something that inspires others who are living with CF I recognize the absolute gift that I'd been given to you know two incredible parents who were so positive and I thought not everyone has that gift and I thought can I be the role model that they were for me to other people who are living with or affected by cystic fibrosis.
凌晨两点，我和老爸坐在那里，等待一些检测结果出来，看看我是不是失血过多需要输血，或者他们是否需要对我的肺部进行手术。我记得看着我爸爸说，老爸，我有一种深深的清醒感，不仅因为我能从这次经历中恢复过来，而且会比以往任何时候都更加强大，但这是我该做点事情的时候了，去激励其他生活在囊性纤维化中的人。我认识到我被赋予了绝对的恩赐，我有两个如此积极向上的不可思议的父母，我想，并不是每个人都有这种恩赐，我想我能否像他们对我的那样，成为其他人（生活在囊性纤维化中或受其影响的人）的榜样。
And I made a declaration in that hospital bed at 2am that by the end of that year, so just four and a half, five months later, I'd run a marathon to show that nothing was impossible and that you could come back from even the absolute worst of, you know, illnesses and issues and challenges in life. And, you know, over the course of that next four and a half months, I figured it out and I got a marathon done.
我在凌晨两点的病房里下定决心，要在今年年底前，也就是短短四个半、五个月后，跑一场马拉松，来证明没有什么是不可能的，你甚至可以从最糟糕的疾病、问题和生活挑战中恢复过来。而且，你知道，在接下来的四个半月里，我摸索着做到了，我完成了一场马拉松。
And it come with so many ups and downs and turbulent moments. But as I crossed the finish line of that marathon, I realized that for the first time in a long time, I'd gone out and set myself an incredibly lofty challenge and I'd proven to myself that I was capable again. It was a feeling I hadn't felt since I was a child that I can control what I choose to control every day.
这一路经历了那么多的起起落落和动荡时刻。但当我冲过马拉松终点线的那一刻，我意识到，长久以来我第一次走出去，为自己设定了一个极其崇高的挑战，我向自己证明了，我又行了。这是一种我从童年起就再没感受过的感觉——我可以控制我每天选择控制的事物。
And I can't control when cystic fibrosis serves me up. some bleeding lungs I can't control when something in my life goes wrong. It's that Tony Robbins quote right that pain is inevitable suffering is a choice but I choose to not suffer over the things I can control every day and I can't even remember the question you asked me when this started but essentially what I'm getting at is it was so important to me to develop that sense of capability through discipline, purpose, and in turn building incredible resilience and even greater perspective that you can't be a victim of your circumstances. You have to own them.
我无法控制囊性纤维化什么时候又让我肺出血，我无法控制我生活中的某件事什么时候会出错。就像托尼·罗宾斯的那句名言一样，痛苦是不可避免的，受苦是一种选择，但我选择每天不去为那些我能控制的事情受苦。我甚至不记得刚开始时你问了我什么问题，但本质上我想说的是，通过纪律、使命感来培养这种能力感，进而建立起不可思议的坚韧和更广阔的视角，这对我来说太重要了——你不能成为你环境的受害者。你必须掌控它们。
You know, you spoke about the cards that you dealt. You don't pick the cards you dealt in a game of poker. You either fold or you play on. And I never fold. I always play on because you have no other option. You know, you can't sit and mull over what is. you may as well use it to your advantage. And essentially, I've found this incredible view and perspective that I am so blessed
你知道的，你谈到了你拿到手的牌。在扑克牌局中，你没得选择抓到什么牌。你要么弃牌，要么继续玩。而我从不弃牌。我总是选择继续，因为你别无选择。你知道，你不能坐着琢磨已经发生的事，你不如好好利用它来为自己谋利。本质上，我发现了一种不可思议的视野和视角，那就是我感到如此幸运，
to have been dealt these cards because it's given me the opportunity to have a story that can impact people, that can uplift people. Like, I don't know that I'd be the man. Well, in fact, I'm certain I wouldn't be the man that I am today had I not been given this challenge. Yeah. Because when you fight something for 26 years, when you fight every day to keep well, to keep healthy. It gives you an immense sense of appreciation. And I'm so grateful for just the little things in
能够拿到这些牌，因为它给了我一个拥有故事的机会，一个能影响人、鼓舞人的故事。就像，我不知道自己会不会成为这样的男人。事实上，我敢肯定，如果没有经历过这个挑战，我绝不会成为今天的我。是的。因为当你与某种东西抗争了26年，当你每天都在努力保持康复、保持健康时，这会赋予你一种巨大的感激之情。我非常感激生命中的那些小事，
my life. And I wouldn't have it any other way. I genuinely, I thought I was going to cry when you were talking about that. Like that part, oh my goodness, like, so incredibly moving. And I just think it shows how much you've taken from that experience. And even on a broader scale, how much our entire identity in some ways the things that we care about most most of it kind of it boils down to two things right it boils down to material and it boils down to internal and I think that was so incredible for me
我不会想去改变任何事。老实说，当你谈到这一点时，我以为自己要哭了。就像那一部分，哦天哪，真的太感人了。我只是觉得这表明你从那段经历中汲取了多少力量。甚至从更广泛的层面上讲，我们在某种程度上整个人的身份认同，我们最在乎的事情，大多数其实都可以归结为两点，对吧？它可以归结为物质，也可以归结为内在。我觉得这真的太不可思议了，
to hear that switch that you made that transition from caring about wealth from caring about status to really caring about the things that mattered like family and like health. And it's just so incredible how life really sometimes I do think forces you on the path that you're meant to go on. And I know this is a psychology podcast.
听到你做出的那种转变——从关心财富、关心地位，转变为真正关心那些重要的事，比如家庭和健康。真的太神奇了，有时候生活确实会强行把你推上注定要走的那条路。我知道这是一个心理学播客。
I can't give any explanation for that. I do just think that it's just something that we're never going to be able to explain. Fate is a very mysterious thing that I absolutely believe in. And I think your story is an incredible, incredible display of that that you came through some incredibly traumatic times to completely realize yourself
我对此无法给出任何解释。我只是觉得有些东西是我们永远无法解释的。命运是一件非常神秘的事情，我是绝对相信的。我觉得你的故事就是一个极其不可思议的展现，你经历了一些极其痛苦的时期，最终彻底实现了自我，
and to be an incredible person and I think the other thing that really moves me about that story is the marathon like I remember you telling me this for the first time and I was like I that is insane to me this man ran a marathon with like having had his lungs
成为了一个不可思议的人。我觉得那个故事中另一个真正触动我的地方是马拉松——我记得你第一次跟我说这件事的时候，我就想，这对我来说太疯狂了，这个人在肺部出血不到四个月的情况下居然去跑了一场马拉松。
bleeding less than four months before. Most people don't run a marathon with fully functional lungs. That's just like insane to me. And I'm sure that's a massive achievement for you. But what are some of the other things that you are so proud of achieving? What are some of the things that you, you know, what are some of the things that your 18-year-old self wouldn't believe that you've done today? Yeah, I love that question as well because I think my 18-year-old self,
大多数肺功能完全正常的人都不会去跑马拉松。这对我来说简直太疯狂了。我确信这对你来说是一个巨大的成就。但你引以为豪的其他成就还有哪些呢？有些什么事情，你知道的，18岁的你绝对不会相信今天的你竟然能做到？是的，我也很喜欢这个问题，因为我想18岁的那个自己，
If I think back to that kid, there was this, I can still tell when I look at him and I look back at old photos, when I look back at things that I'd written on Facebook or, you know, there's horrifying memories pop up on the timeline. And they stretch it out a little bit and I look back at that. And there was still this sense of a kid who wanted to help others, who understood the power of service. but when I talk about the podcast making a man out of me, I truly mean it. I remember and have this long term passion for storytelling. You know, my parents were telling me not too long ago
如果我回想那个孩子，还有那种……我依然能从自己身上看出来，当我回看旧照片，回看我在Facebook上写过的内容，或者，你知道的，时间线上弹出的那些可怕的记忆。他们把它稍微延伸了一下，我回过头去看。那里依然有一种孩子般的气息，想要帮助别人，懂得服务的力量。但当我谈到播客塑造了一个真正的我时，我是认真的。我记得并且长期对讲故事充满热情。你知道的，我父母不久前还告诉我，
that my first words were a sentence, that I had this love, desire to consistently ask people questions, share stories, connect with people, wherever we went. I was always more interested in having a conversation with the adults because they could talk more than just running off and playing with the kids. Like, I had this genuine love for conversation and storytelling.
我的第一句话就是一个完整的句子，我有着一种热爱、一种渴望，无论走到哪里，都不断地向人们提问、分享故事、与人建立联系。我对和成年人对话总是比跑去和孩子们玩更感兴趣，因为大人能聊的话题更多。就像，我对谈话和讲故事有着真挚的热爱。
And so when I started the podcast, it was me recognizing that for a few years, I'd done what I thought I had to do to be, quote, unquote, successful in the world, to accumulate wealth, to buy a home, to have a nice car, to wear fancy suits to be what other people would deem to be impressive. And in the pursuit of that, I'd completely forgotten what was impressive, enjoyable, you know, passionate for me. And so when I started the podcast, it was a reconnection with an old passion. And just like lighting a candle, that flame was back as strong as it used to be.
所以当我开始做播客时，是我意识到在过去几年里，我一直在做我以为为了在世俗中获得“成功”、积累财富、买房、买豪车、穿名牌西装、成为别人眼中“让人印象深刻”的人而不得不做的事。而在对这些的追求中，我完全忘记了什么才是对我来说真正印象深刻、享受的、充满热情的。因此，当我开始做播客时，那是与旧日热情的重新连接。就像点燃一支蜡烛，那火焰像以前一样熊熊燃烧起来，
and I felt a sense of not only enjoyment in the early days of the podcast, but I felt this attachment to purpose. Because I remember the second episode of the show, it's now at 176, 77 episodes, which is wild to me. But I remember just after the second episode, I released the first three on the same day. And it was the day after I'd released them, I got a message from a girl who lived locally,
我不仅在播客的早期感受到了乐趣，还感受到了一种与使命感的紧密联系。因为我记得节目的第二集——现在已经播到176、177集了，这让我觉得很疯狂。但我记得就在第二集之后，我把前三集在同一天发布了。就在发布后的第二天，我收到了一条私信，来自一个当地的女孩，
who said to me that the second episode, which was a lot of it was with a mental health foundation, she said that it had helped her reconnect with her partner who was going through a really tough time because he just lost his dad. And that same day, I remember having sold two homes and, you know, getting that boost of commission and paycheck through and looking at that, feeling that feeling, and then comparing it to how good and amazing and inspiring it felt to get this message, just a message from someone who had been moved, uplifted, inspired by a conversation that I'd hosted.
她对我说，第二集——其中很大一部分是和一个心理健康基金会合作的，她说那一集帮助她重新联系上了正经历艰难时刻的伴侣，因为他的父亲刚刚去世。而就在同一天，我记得自己卖了两套房子，拿到了佣金和薪水的提成，看着那一串数字，感受着那种感觉，然后把它与收到这条信息时的美好、惊叹和受鼓舞的感觉进行对比——仅仅是来自一个被我主持的对话所打动、受到提升和鼓舞的人的一条信息。
And I thought, far out, that's a feeling I do not want to forget. Like, I want to continue to feel that because it was a sense of service. Yeah. And, like, true purpose. And I remember connecting with that feeling. and I've gone on throughout the course of the last three years to have so many unique and diverse conversations with people who I likely would have never met
我想，天哪，这种感觉我绝不想忘记。我想继续感受这种感觉，因为它是一种奉献精神。是的，还有真正的使命感。我记得自己与那种感觉紧密相连，在过去的三年里，我继续与各种各样独特的人进行过如此多的对话，如果没有这个播客，我可能永远不会遇到他们，
or being connected to without the podcast. And I think as teenagers, we're quite stubborn, right? We think that our problems are the only problems in the world and that our first world problems are the biggest problems and that everyone should handle their problems the way that we do and everyone should think the way that we think. And when you sit down in front of people, you can sense, feel their emotion, when you hear their story and recognize that everyone has lived
或者与他们产生交集。我想作为青少年时，我们都相当顽固，对吧？我们认为自己的问题是世界上唯一的问题，我们温室里的问题是最大的问题，每个人都应该用我们的方式去处理问题，每个人都应该和我们想的一样。而当你坐在人们面前，你能感知、感受到他们的情绪，当你倾听他们的故事，认识到每个人的生活方式各不相同，你会相当快地明白，生活远比你宏大，你不过是一个庞大宇宙中的一个小点，这个宇宙充满了不同的人、不同的经历和不同的故事。
differently, you pretty quickly learn that life is far bigger than you, that you are literally a blip in a massive universe that is full of different people, different experiences and different stories. And in that understanding and in that development over the course of three years, I'm so, so proud of the man it's made out of me because I am far like I never understood the power of being vulnerable and now I literally lead into every conversation I have with this sense of desire to be vulnerable this understanding of my purpose this understanding of the fact that I want to do something to impact the people not only in my life but the people who tune into what I do and so I'm so proud and I think if you showed 18 year old Brad what 26 year old Brad was doing
带着这种理解，在三年的成长过程中，我对它塑造出的我感到无比骄傲——因为我远比……我以前从未理解脆弱的力量，而现在我几乎将脆弱融入了我的每一次对话中，带着对使命的理解，带着这样的理解：我想做点事情去影响我生命中的人，以及那些收听我节目的人。所以我感到非常自豪，我想如果让18岁的布拉德看到26岁的布拉德在做的事情，
he'd go, that's my dream life. Oh my gosh. And that's such a nice feeling. It's a nice feeling for me to even hear that, honestly. To hear that is so compelling to me. And I think such just, yeah, so profound and so compelling. And something that you said then that I think is such a motivator for me is that existential sense of your place in this universe and your place in this world.
他会说，这简直是我梦寐以求的生活。哦天哪。这真是一种美好的感觉。老实听到这些，对我也有一种美好的感觉。听到这些对我有极大的吸引力。我觉得真的很深刻，也很有吸引力。你当时说的一句话，我认为对我是一个巨大的动力，那就是关于你在宇宙中的位置以及在这个世界上的位置的那种存在主义感知。
sometimes we need to take a step back. I truly do believe this and understand that we are so small and understand that we are so tiny in the grand scheme of things. And by positioning ourselves, by being rational in that sense of understanding where we sit in the world, you're able to have so much more freedom and so much more, I would say so much more freedom and so much more authenticity and so much more. propensity for passion because you realize that what you do doesn't matter but what you do doesn't matter so you in those moments you're like really I get to make a choice here am I going to do something that like in this short time that I have really touches people and brings that connection and makes my life happier and better and deeper or am I going to do something because of
有时候我们需要退后一步。我真的坚信这一点，并明白我们是如此渺小，明白在宏大的计划中我们是如此微不足道。通过调整我们的位置，通过在理解我们在世界上所处位置时保持理性，你能够拥有更多的自由，更多的——我想说的是，更多的自由、更多的真实性、以及对热情的更多倾向，因为你意识到你所做的事其实无足轻重，但正因为你所做的事无足轻重，所以在那些时刻你会想：真的，我在这里做出了选择，我是要做一件在我有生之年真正能触动人们、带来连接、让我的生活更快乐、更美好、更深刻的事情，还是我要去做一件出于
of material reasons or because I'm scared of judgment or because I'm scared of being held back by my illness or by what other people think or by my circumstances. So I do think that's an incredible reminder. I want to finish on this question because it's something I love to ask people who have amazing stories such as your own and something that I think is really valuable from learning or something that's really valuable to learn from people such as yourself. And that is what advice would you give to someone in your shoes? What advice would you give to someone with CF or someone who's been through the life transitions and the decisions that you've been through?
物质原因、或者因为我害怕评判、或者因为我害怕被我的疾病所阻碍、或者被别人的看法所阻碍、或者被我的处境所阻碍的事情。所以我认为这是一个不可思议的提醒。我想以这个问题来结束，因为这是我喜欢问那些拥有像你一样精彩故事的人的问题，也是我认为从像你这样的人身上学习非常有价值的东西。那就是：你会给处在你当时境地的人什么建议？你会给患有囊性纤维化的人，或者经历过你所经历的生活转变和决定的人什么建议？
If you get the gift of today, which is waking up with air and your lungs and a heartbeat, then you have been given this incredible blessing. And I think we often look at the future and have these big desires, dreams, hopes, things that we want to achieve. But it's understanding that it all starts with today. And I would just encourage people to recognize that blessing and appreciate the fact that if you get tomorrow, you're even luckier than you are today. And so just don't look too far ahead and don't be too harsh on yourself for where you are now. because for so long I beat myself up about all the things that I wasn't doing or wasn't achieving and become insecure about the things that I wasn't when I compared myself to where other men at 26 were
如果你得到了今天这份礼物，那就是带着呼吸和心跳醒来，那么你已经得到了这个不可思议的祝福。我想我们经常注视着未来，有着这些宏大的欲望、梦想、希望、我们想要实现的事情。但我们要明白，这一切都始于今天。我只想鼓励人们认识到这份祝福，并去感激这样一个事实：如果你能迎来明天，你就会比今天更幸运。所以，不要把目光看得太远，不要对现在的自己太严苛，
or where other men at 20 were or 18, whatever stage of my life. And, you know, it's so easy to look at yourself and go, these are all the things that I'm not. But you're you for a reason. And I'm just going to drag this out a little bit longer because there's one thing that I want to repeat that I heard actually just an hour before we jumped on this. pod. I heard Chris Williamson, a guy that I've been really enjoying listening to at the moment, giving a TED talk. And he spoke about how, I think it's like a four trillion to one chance that you are born as you. And he spoke about how fascinating and incredible the odds of you being alive as you on this earth are. And he said, I often hear people talk about all these amazing
因为很长一段时间里，我一直在因为自己没有做所有这些事或没有取得成就而自责，当我把自己与26岁或20岁或18岁的其他男人在生命的某个阶段进行比较时，我对自己的不足感到没有安全感。而且，你知道，审视自己然后说“这些全都是我做不到的事”是如此容易。但你成为你自己是有原因的。我要把这个话题稍微延伸一点，因为有一件事我想重复一下，其实就在我们连线录音前的一个小时我刚听到。我听了克里斯·威廉姆森的TED演讲，他是我最近很喜欢听的一个人。他谈到，我觉得大约是四万亿分之一的几率，你才得以作为你自己出生。他谈到你作为自己活在这个地球上的几率是多么迷人和不可思议。他说，我经常听到人们谈论他们生活中所有这些惊人的
dreams and challenges and hopes they have for their life. But they always, striving to be like someone else if you're striving to be like someone else or you can ever be as average because if you are like everyone else who's doing what you want to do in that space then you're just going to be one of many the beauty of life is you get to be one of one because there is no one like you there is no other like you and as human beings we have to embrace that and the minute moment point in time in which i lent into who i was and accepted it for all of the challenges that i have all of the things that I'm not and just believe that you know what I am who I am and I should be proud of that and it has armed me with this incredible sense of appreciation and perspective that I have the power
梦想、挑战和希望。但如果你一直在努力成为别人，如果你总是努力去成为别人，你最多也只能变得平庸，因为如果你像其他人一样在那个领域做你想做的事，那你不过是芸芸众生中的一个。生命的美妙之处在于，你可以成为独一无二的那一个，因为没有人像你，没有其他人像你。作为人类，我们必须拥抱这一点。当我倾向于做真实的自己，并接受自己所有的挑战、所有做不到的事情，并且相信，你知道吗，我就是我，我应该为此感到自豪——正是这个微小的瞬间，赋予了我一种不可思议的感激之情和视角，让我拥有了力量，
to do great things in life and I'll just say to people stop comparing yourself to others look yourself in the mirror accept who you are and move forward and make an impact on your small corner of the world and that starts with the people in your life and if it inspires you to make bigger moves and have bigger impact, well, then that's amazing. But it all starts with you being proud of who you are. Yeah. I could not agree more. I think it's just such a,
在生活中做伟大的事情。我要对人们说的是：停止与他人比较，照照镜子，接受你是谁，然后向前迈进，在你世界的小角落里产生影响，而这始于你生命中的人。如果它能激励你采取更大的行动并产生更大的影响，嗯，那当然太棒了。但这一切都始于为你自己是谁而感到自豪。是的。我不能同意更多了。我认为这真的是一个，
I think that is just such a great statement and a great piece of advice. So inspiring, genuinely. I'm sitting here contemplating how I can impact my small corner, how I can be more like myself. I think we talked about this on, when I was on your show, the dangers of comparison,
我认为这真是一个伟大的陈述和极好的建议。真的很受鼓舞。我坐在这里思考，我该如何影响我的小角落，我该如何更像我自己。我想我们在……当我做客你的节目时，我们谈论过比较的危险，
specifically downward social comparison and how it can really put you in a bad space. So I completely agree with what you had to say there. I just want to say, thank you so much for coming on. That was personally, it felt like it was just us. And it is just us, but it's crazy to me that people are going to be listening to this because it did just move me so personally in this moment. So thank you so much for taking the time out of your day to come and speak to me.
特别是向下的社会比较，以及它如何真正把你带入一个糟糕的境地。所以我完全同意你所说的一切。我只想说，非常感谢你能来。对我个人而言，感觉就像只有我们俩在对话。虽然确实只有我们俩，但一想到人们会听到这个，我就觉得太疯狂了，因为它此刻确实深深地触动了我。所以非常感谢你抽出时间来和我交谈。
Honestly, it's been such a pleasure, Jan. And, you know, when we met not too long ago now at Spotify HQ, I remember walking away with my partner, Sof, and just us speaking so positively about the connection we had with you because it felt so authentic. And I think, you know, they say birds of a feather flock together. And I think that night we connected on authenticity and the fact that we wanted to do good for the people
老实说，这真是我的荣幸，简。你知道，不久前我们在Spotify总部见面时，我记得我和我的伴侣索夫离开时，我们一直在积极地谈论我们与你的连接，因为它感觉是如此真实。我想，你知道的，物以类聚，人以群分。我想那天晚上我们在真实性上产生了共鸣，以及我们想要为那些
who tuned into our shows and whatever we do in this world. And it's just been such a blessing. and a pleasure to get to know you and to now connect on our shows. And I'm so moved by what you've been able to do. And the amazing things that are now happening for you with the psychology of your 20s, you deserve every little bit of it. And I'm just so blessed to be a part of the show's fabric now. And I hope that people have enjoyed this chat.
收听我们节目的人、为我们在世界上所做的一切做好事的愿望。能认识你并现在在我们的节目中产生连接，真是一大幸事和荣幸。我对你所做的一切深感触动。现在“你的二十岁心理学”（The Psychology of Your 20s）正在发生的那些奇妙事情，是你应得的每一分成果。我非常荣幸能成为这个节目架构的一部分。我希望人们会喜欢这次畅谈。
And, you know, if people want to continue to connect, you know, reach out to me, send me a message. Let me know whether you listen to this episode or not and what you loved about it. I just love having conversations with people. And, you know, I love hearing that this stuff has impacted and uplifted the people who tune in. Yeah, absolutely. All of Bradley's links will be in the description of this episode. They'll be on Instagram.
而且，你知道，如果人们想继续保持联系，你知道的，联系我，给我发信息。让我知道你是否听了这一集，以及你最喜欢它的什么地方。我就是喜欢和人们对话。而且，你知道，我喜欢听到这些内容能够对那些收听的人产生影响并给他们带来提升。是的，绝对的。布拉德的所有链接都会在本集的简介中。它们会在Instagram上。
You should really go and listen to his show. Some of the most incredible conversations and interviews I've ever heard, you don't get enough credit for how vulnerable and candid you are and how talented you are at speaking and conversing with anyone. It's just such a, it's genuinely a gift. It's something that I think very few people have. So it was just so great to have you on. And a reminder that if you did enjoy this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star
你真的应该去听听他的节目。那是我听过最不可思议的一些对话和采访，对于你有多么脆弱和坦率，以及你在说话和与任何人对话时有多么才华横溢，你并没有得到足够的赞誉。这真的是一个天赋。我认为这是极少数人拥有的能力。所以能请你来做客真的太棒了。提醒大家，如果你喜欢这一集，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或任何你收听节目的地方留下五星
review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you get your shows. It really helps the show to grow and reach new people and share this episode with a friend who you think might benefit from this conversation. I think it was such a valuable conversation. just for me and I already knew what we were going to talk about. So I'm sure that for them, it might be just as valuable. And if you want to get involved with the community, if you want to reach out, you have episode suggestions, follow us at that psychology podcast.
好评。这真的对节目的成长和触达新听众大有帮助，也请把这一集分享给你认为可能会从中受益的朋友。我认为这是一场非常有价值的对话，哪怕对我来说也是如此，而我本来就知道我们要聊什么。所以我确信对他们而言，这同样会非常有价值。如果你想参与到社群中，如果你想联系我们，有节目建议，请在That Psychology Podcast关注我们。
Bradley's links will be in the description of this episode. Please go and listen to a lot to talk about and follow him on Instagram, TikTok, everywhere. Thank you so much. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever.
布拉德的链接会放在本集的简介中。请一定要去听听，有很多内容值得探讨，并在Instagram、TikTok等各个地方关注他。非常感谢。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客“2%”中，我将剖析我们这个奇异现代世界中心理坚韧、健身和培养韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听“2%”。也就是TWO.%。
you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
在“回看过去”（Look Back at It）播客中。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个大时刻。84年对我也意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I mean, it was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app,
并试着去理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的人以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。我是说，那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeart Radio应用、
Apple Podcasts, wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional
Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听“回看过去”。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯主持的“艰难学步”（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方其实都不安全，但你是在和一个懂行的
who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to Learn the Hardway on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲？它向世界释放的信号是：你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力，并不意味着你需要这么做，在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听“艰难学步”。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown.
但这妊娠似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑都要炸了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是“受困的爱”（Love Trapped）。斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听“受困的爱”播客。这是一档iHeart播客。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。